welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and if you're losing your
patience like a bad doctor then this is
the multiverse of madness video for you
throughout it we're going to be building
on our last plot leak video and
discussing all the new info that we now
have on the movie i want to get straight
into it but obviously there will be some
major spoilers here if these leaks turn
out to be true and i can't cast a memory
spell to make you forget anything so
check out now if you don't want things
ruined with that out of the way a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so if you've been following the
channel for a while then you might have
seen our last plot league breakdown that
we did all the way back in october
detailing major elements of the movie
since the trailer's release it looks
like a majority of these things are
indeed true and though we know there's
been some reshoots it looks like most of
the plot elements we talked about in
that are still in place now if you've
already watched that video and just want
to see us talk about the post credits
scene then time codes will be linked
below so use that time stone now you're
punk anyway the movie is basically going
to be a multiversal battle between
doctor strange and wonder as she
attempts to take america chevez's powers
so that she can travel to a dimension in
order to get her kids hide your wife
hide your kids hide your human looking
vibrator because the woman don't stop
when it comes to getting what she wants
i don't want to just go over old ground
though so if you want to have a beat by
b play on how the movie pans out then
make sure you check out that plot league
video which will be linked on screen
right now this is mainly covering the
new details we've heard but as always
take them with a pinch of salt as you
know how things can get chewed up in the
rumor mill now a new bit of info that
we've learned since then is that the
book of ashanti will play a big part in
the film you could probably figure this
out from the trailers and the book even
featured on the poster just behind
strange it's basically the opposite of
the dark hold and whereas that corrupts
bishanti contains pure light and
positive emotions like that feeling you
get when someone hits a thumbs up button
like wonder wants to hit those ultron
butts god damn so sexy god damn anyway
we can catch the book in the trailer on
a pedestal in the dimension that strange
america and the christine variant travel
to you might recognize this as being the
same location that has defender strange
there and apparently he's one of the
only people in the multiverse that knows
the location of it he america are on a
long variant traveler at the start of
the movie but they're ambushed by a red
ribbon-like monster and this is when
defender strange saves her from being
killed by it he pushes her to your
portal and both he and wong are killed
by the creature and now this death
apparently sends shockwaves across the
multiverse and the mcu version sees it
all play out in a nightmare he wakes up
in his bed which we see in the trailers
and we're meant to learn that he has
nightmares every night in which he dies
these are actually his variants across
the multiverse and the person killing
them is actually wonder now in case you
are wondering hey what she's been up to
the darkhold has basically corrupted her
completely and early on we're going to
be getting a scene where mordo visits
her at the log cabin that we saw at the
end of one division when we last left
him at the end of doctor strange he was
out hunting the sorceress around the
world and he now has his sights set on
the skull at which things don't go the
way he plan and wonder kills him like
they did to all your hopes of us getting
an orated kingpin that slams heads and
car doors god damn you hawkeye now at
the wedding a big squidward monster
attacks new york and this is chasing
after america we then see strange fight
in the middle of the street to protect
her and this is the scene in which he
cuts the bus in half thank god it had no
one on board and the mcu is so lucky
that in both this and the eternals that
people just don't ride buses in heavily
populated cities now this giant monster
is gargantos and we learn later on that
wonder has been summoning these
creatures through the dark hold so that
she can get america strange goes to
visit her in order to help fix the
multiverse as he thinks it's breaking up
in his link to the events of spider-man
no way home in which he helped out
peace
some some some idiot anyway it's at this
point we see her garden is actually an
illusion and this was somewhat confirmed
in the trailer by these shots in which
strange is wearing the same clothes and
the positions are mirrored strange
manages to get away and he takes america
to commentage where the wizards make
their last stand against voldemort
wonder rolls in on a cloud of smoke and
from what i've been told unlike what we
see in the trailers the cloud is
actually red it's just had its colour
change to not give too much away wonder
wipes out most of the wizards and
strange decides to travel with america
into the multiverse in order to find
vashanti because defender strange was
the person who knew where it was located
they decide to head to that reality
which is where we get the statue seen a
very namorno comes across strange in
america blames them for basically
destroying several universes and he then
drugs their tea and takes them before
the illuminati now we still don't have
their lineup fully confirmed and every
time i speak to my source they tell me
there's been changes and additions in
the reshoots we can't out and out say
who's in the illuminati outside of jay-z
but the people i'm constantly told are
in it are captain carter from what if
professor x who's now in a chair similar
to the one from the x-men cartoon maria
rambo is this universe's captain marvel
and john krasinski as mr fantastic we
can tell from the chairs in the scene
that there's a lot more members but
again i keep getting told different
things about who's in it i've heard tom
cruise a black panther variant neymar
bruce campbell and even deadpool i don't
know how legit those are and from the
looks of it they've cgi'd out several
other members like stalin used to when
he'd fall out with a mate over whether
dc or marvel was better very very niche
joke there now they're basically the
guardians of the multiverse and they
have gates that can open up every
universe even the one where mysterio was
right oh wait that's the mcu and every
single reality mysterio was right durio
was right stop we don't that's all now
though wander isn't able to travel
through dimensions like america can she
can still astral project and she ends up
taking the body of a varian in the
ultron bot timeline she then attacks the
illuminati base and all the members of
the group she even kills professor x and
this kinda segues us into our first
post-credits scene now according to the
leaks this is going to feature deadpool
cable domino and vanessa who show up to
the illuminati base it's revealed that
the multiversal gates have been left
open and because of this they're able to
come across and then move into the mcu
deadpool makes a couple of jokes about
the members of the group being dead and
one about professor x being dead for
like the third time now during the
kerfuffle it's a bit of a kerfuffle
strange and chavez flee across the
multiverse with christine and apparently
this takes place in a number of
different worlds again these might be
changed might not be in the bloody movie
but they do seem to be in the trailer
the worlds included 2d ones similar to
what if the savage land which is full of
dinosaurs and some cube worlds so be
there or be square you punk eventually
they end up in a reality with a variant
of strange supreme from what if who's
basically made a kickoff more than
twitter has been over that two second
shot of flash thompson in no way home
one ends up going into another reality
where her kids are and here she comes
across one who ended up getting that
house in west view she attacks this
version of herself and when the kids see
this they run away scared warner then
throws everything she can at strange and
both she and america end up fighting
across the multiverse unable to get to
the dimension they're in strange has to
astral project and he takes over
defender strange's corpse which we
somewhat saw in the trailers they all
battle it out and wonder is kicked into
the multiverse to a fate that we don't
find out about in this movie back in the
mcu timeline were meant to see wong and
strange training america in order to
hone her powers they've also got the
darkhold with them and this is meant to
carry over into the post-credits scene
for the film we catch strange ones more
in a bear like how he was at the start
of the movie and he has another
nightmare this time he catches a version
of himself in a ruined new york city
with a dead wong in the sanctorum we can
also see kang the conqueror there played
once more by jonathan mages strangers
training dormammu sister umar and the
pair are pouring over the dark hold
whilst kang stands there smiling strange
manifests a third eye and then the mcu
version wakes up which is when we hear
the voice of clear played by charlie's
throne she says help me and we see that
the mcu version of strange forms his own
third eye which ends the movie so lots
of things going on in the film and i'm
very excited to see it when it releases
in may again i'm not sure how accurate
this is but if you go back and watch
your video from october then it does
seem to line up with the trailer that
was released shortly after these details
kind of expand on that info and i'm
really excited to see what they do with
the x-men characters and cameos in the
film i've heard there's actually a
number of them that haven't been leaked
yet and the big one that's currently
going around at the moment is tom cruise
he might be appearing as an iron man
variant but much like the illuminati
i've heard a lot of conflicting reports
but i do really hope that they get the
guy in it there's also no mention of
white vision and maybe they're saving
him for more stuff down the line it was
announced last month that elizabeth
allison has just signed a seven year
contract with marvel studios so no doubt
they'll have plans for him at some point
i think they just kind of want to throw
her off the deep end at the moment and
showcase to us what kind of threat she
can be wandering the comics is always a
wild card and house of m very much dealt
with the x-men and avengers weighing up
whether they should kill her or not
because of how dangerous that she is i
really hope that's the direction they
take things as we've got to know here
since age of ultron and it would put the
audience in a position of us weighing up
whether we want to see her happy at the
cost of the multiverse lots of
fascinating things i can do with her and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the video and all the new details
make sure you drop some comments below
on whether you believe the leaks what
you'd like to see in the movie and all
that good stuff i've got a bit of a sore
throat right now need to see a doctor
myself so hopefully my voice hasn't got
any nerves and you actually found it
sexy no one else does but hopefully you
have now we are in competition right now
and giving away three copies of no way
home on the 15th of april the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
don't miss out on this amazing
opportunity to get a free movie if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out a breakdown of
spider-man now at home and all the
easter eggs in it one of our best videos
ever got some great cameos in it too so
definitely go head over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace